André Mayet Perrière vous êtes président
du Réseau québécois pour la réussite
éducative bonjour bonjour vous étiez
dans le reportage et vous vous étiez
effectivement d'accord pour qu'on mette
un âge minimal donc vous êtes très
content aujourd'hui on est très
satisfait c'était l'équilibré bon
André Martin vésinat vice-président des
affaires publiques de l'Association des
restaurateurs du Québec vous vous êtes
moins contents on est effectivement
moins content avec un âge ferme à 14 ans
c'est sûr que c'est pas ce qu'on
cherchait là vous avez besoin dites-vous
de cette main d'oeuvre là nous on a
juste sondé nos membres dernièrement 254
répondants le tianes ont dit qu'ils
avaient utilisaient ce bassin de
travailleur là pour environ 7 heures par
semaine donc nous on est d'accord avec
la disposition sur le nombre d'heures
maximales et c'est là qu'on devrait
mettre le cadre du projet de loi plutôt
qu'un âge minimal on va y revenir mais
André maillet dites-moi quels sont les
risques est-ce que c'est une question de
réussite scolaire c'est ça qui
commençait à grandement inquiéter
beaucoup d'intervenants oui
effectivement on a quand même peu de
données sur les impacts du travail en
bas de 14 ans mais on le sait que c'est
un moment de la vie des gens ou ils lui
font le passage au secondaire pour pour
cette jeune sur 10 à cette période
exactement de leur vie ils vont vivre un
passage altéré dans cette base de
rendement scolaire augmentation de
l'anxiété diminution de la motivation
diminution de l'engagement scolaire avec
nous on pense qu'on va 14 ans la
priorité d'un jeune c'est un métier
c'est d'être élève on pense quand même
que travailler c'est bon c'est pour ça
qu'on est favorable l'encadrement aussi
puis qu'on permette même c'est la
scolarité est obligatoire scolaire de 16
ans des caillasses qu'on voit dans la
législation c'est un arrimage complet
obligatoire pas le droit de travailler
ici c'est plus nuancé si on regarde les
blessés au travail ça va un peu dans
votre sens parce qu'il y en a plus de
jeunes qui se blessent on a un tableau
là il y a eu une augmentation au cours
des années 2017 jusqu'à 2021 puis je dis
pas monsieur vinaigre c'est dans les
restaurants
et la proportion de jeunes qui
travaillent a Bondy en janvier 20 22 et
janvier 20-23 vous allez voir les
chiffres de 13 à 54% pour le premier
secondaire et de 21 à 57% pour
secondaire 2 donc ça c'est le contexte
donc monsieur vizenavo vous dites on
aurait dû dire
dizaines d'heures quinzaine d'heures
maximum mais il y a des jeunes
dites-vous de 12-13 ans qui sont prêts
les travailler puis c'est bon pour eux
nous on croit qu'effectivement il y a
des compétences de savoir vivre à
obtenir dans un emploi rémunéré et nous
comme je l'ai dit en moyenne de travail
par semaine donc on n'est pas dans un
contexte avec les jeunes de moins de 14
ans à aller dans des 20-25 heures on
comprend et on est d'accord à ce que la
réussite scolaire soit la priorité
cependant avec un âge ferme à 14 ans ça
veut dire que pendant un jeune qui
voudrait travailler dans un casse-croûte
cet été qui est 13 ans et 8 mois en
juillet ben il pourra pas travailler
cette année mais peut-être il y a un
intérêt et peut-être ça va déjà aimer il
va avoir d'autres compétences aller
chercher pour ceux qu'on est déçu
d'aller aussi futur dans la loi et
parler avec des exemptions soit sur des
postes ou sur des secteurs d'activité et
je comprends que vous prenez le point de
vue du jeûne mais en fait vous c'est le
point de vue des restaurateurs vous
dites où on va aller trouver cette main
d'oeuvre là parce qu'il y en a des
jeunes qui l'avaient la vaisselle qui
était bossboy pour apprendre
l'expression et tout à fait on a le
dernier sondage qu'on a fait le tiers
des répondants nous ont dû utiliser
cette main d'oeuvre là j'ai moins de 14
ans pas beaucoup d'heures mais c'est un
axe même si le petit star qui donne mais
ça permet toute une équipe de pouvoir
opérer et c'est sûr que ça va amener des
questionnements des à réduire peut-être
la date d'ouverture vous vous dites il y
a peut-être à la marge des cas où c'est
très bon pour des jeunes de 12-13 ans
mais de façon générale c'est mieux de
pas travailler trop à ça là oui on pense
que par rapport à leur développement
c'est vraiment un moment critique à
l'adolescence c'est la découverte de soi
c'est la socialisation c'est l'entrée au
secondaire on pense que ça devrait
vraiment être seul la priorité on pense
aussi que
s'insérer sur le marché du travail ça
doit soit dans des bonnes conditions
avoir un une maturité aussi face à ça
être bien accompagné on a vraiment vu
que les jeunes qui travaillent le plus
ce sont aussi jeunes les jeunes qui ont
le moins de motivation donc on veut
vraiment prendre le risque qu'avec les
vraiment plus jeune que ce soit une voix
de de en fait on ajoute une distraction
en facile cumule des activités qui
comptent des fois moi je propose de le
voir à l'envers le jeune il y a combien
d'heures pour dormir socialiser aller à
l'école ça lui laisse combien pour ses
loisirs s'ils travaillent est-ce qu'il
va découvrir son école secondaire le
parascolaire comment ça se passe
ailleurs dans d'autres législations
est-ce que est-ce qu'on rejoint
l'ensemble des gens où on deviendra
l'exception on était déjà l'exception en
permettant le travail des jeunes qui
sont soumis à la scolarisation
obligatoire en général c'est arrivé on
est obligé d'aller à l'école jusqu'à 16
ans on n'a pas le droit de travailler de
façon formelle avant 16 ans donc c'est
pour ça que je dis qu'il y a quand même
un bon équilibre parce qu'on pense quand
même que travailler c'est pas c'est
c'est bon ça peut aider le jeune à
développer son autonomie à faire des
découvertes nourrir des aspirations mais
tout ça faut avoir un certain niveau de
maturité peut être capable aussi de
mettre ses limites avec son employeur
puis on pense qu'à partir de 14 ans
c'est bien assez tôt vous vous plaidez
pour qu'il y a des exceptions par
exemple si les parents sont d'accord si
l'enfant réussit bien l'école si si il y
en avait dans le reportage qu'on a
présenté il y a quelques semaines il y
avait une jeune fille qui qui est
championne de ski elle travaille avant
l'école
aucun problème à 13 ans aller travailler
là donc vous dites il faut avoir ça en
tête aussi oui il faut avoir en tête
justement que des jeunes qui veulent
travailler c'est pour ça que le bout du
projet de loi qu'on trouve bien qui
devrait son cœur c'est la limite d'un
maximum de travail pendant la période
scolaire et ce qui est proposé dans le
projet de loi nous convient amplement et
c'est là qu'on devrait accès plutôt que
avec des un ange minimum en Colombo
britannique effectivement c'est 14 ans
mais il prévoit des exemptions y compris
pour la restauration L'employeur peut
demander à la cnsst de cette province là
d'obtenir une autorisation donc il y a
des choses qui peuvent se faire aussi en
bas de 14 ans est-ce que vous seriez
d'accord pour qu'il y a des quelques
exceptions dans le domaine de la
restauration
c'est vraiment très spécifique comme
exception que je suis pas capable de me
prononcer mais ce qu'on a entendu dans
certaines régions c'est peut-être l'été
des gestes de 13 ans mais pendant
l'année scolaire ce qu'on nous rapporte
aussi le CD ça fait longtemps c'est une
chose mais pendant l'été pendant l'été
mais c'est ça mais faut que ça se passe
dans des bonnes conditions plus c'est
toute la question de santé sécurité au
travail ou là moi je suis vraiment pas
une experte mais qui semble avoir des
préoccupations avec le secteur de la
restauration puis ça pour nous s'assurer
que les jeunes sont dans des milieux ou
les adultes prennent soin de leur santé
de leur développement puis que ils sont
accompagnés là-dedans pour nous c'est ça
la priorité ils vendent comme ça
parlementaire vous allez aller plaider
que des exceptions pour l'été dans les
petits restaurants mais il y a une ça
c'est une chose mais travailler toute
l'année dans un gros restaurant elle
avait la vaisselle puis moins étudié sur
une autre chose vous comprenez pas oui
on comprend ça mais nous on vise tout on
vise pas juste la période en dehors de
l'école on vise tout mais je vous dirai
survenir sur la santé sécurité là parce
qu'on dit beaucoup le cas des risques
nous on a évalué avec notre mutuelle de
prévention s'il y avait beaucoup plus
d'accidents de travail dans notre
secteur pour les jeunes âgés de moins de
16 ans or c'est le même nombre en 2002
qu'en 2019 il y a plus de plus de
travailleurs de ce bassin là donc on
peut pas croire justement que c'est la
restauration qui explique les chiffres
proposa un gouvernement des
augmentations d'accidents de travail on
est plus dans Émile Zola les mines non
plus mais il faut faire attention en
tout cas bref ça va être un débat vous
allez vendre comme ça parlementaire il y
a des gens ce qu'il y aura plus
d'ouverture ou pas du ministre on le
recevra aussi un jour merci beaucoup
d'être nu en studio très intéressant